c'est quand même le numéro un mondial
ouais c'est le record en record man du
monde des gains c'est celui qui a gagné
le plus d'argent au tournoi novak
djokovic devant nadal devant federer et
il m'a dit d'accord champion du monde
deux minutes ils font des mini ping pong
vraiment wawrinka au caire jeudi éclaté
gasquet joue éclaté gaël monfils
on m'a approché benoît paire
j'ai jamais perdu tu as le jeu le tabac
est là est ce que tu veux pas ce que tu
veux tenter contre morale autre numéro
[Rires]
[Musique]
samir l'enquêté ok je pense à mon sens
en trois points gagnants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas les seuls à y échoue il va tu dois
attaquer faut pas taper à bas
[Musique]
au toucher
oui
non
[Musique]
tu vas t'entraîner
c'est rien
d
c'est la guerre
radio tous les cas